one of the promises of bitcoin is that
it will help protect your purchasing
power and of course this becomes even
more relevant if you happen to live in a
country where your native currency is
losing tons of value that's exactly
what's been happening in argentina for
years now currently people in argentina
are living through over 50 percent
annual inflation that means that their
purchasing power is being eroded at a
historic pace and so naturally as they
go to look for a solution bitcoin
becomes one of the things that they
start to buy now of course buying
bitcoin is pretty difficult you got to
go sign up for an account on one of the
exchanges you got to learn about bitcoin
then you've got to get your money into
the account and purchase the bitcoin for
yourself and so naturally there are tons
of financial institutions and
organizations that want to help their
customers just accomplish the activities
that they're trying to accomplish and
that's exactly what the largest bank by
private market cap in argentina just
announced a couple days ago and also one
of the largest digital banks in the
country as well but of course as soon as
these two banks in argentina said they
were gonna help their customers buy
bitcoin or other cryptocurrencies the
central bank went into full-on panic
mode and now the central bank has
announced brand new rules that will
prevent any argentinian bank or
financial institution from helping their
customers by bitcoin or cryptocurrencies
of course the central bank's not going
to say that it's a form of capital
control they're not going to try to be
abrasive to the banks or to the
individual citizen but instead they're
saying that they have concerns around
money laundering cyber crime and the
volatility of cryptocurrencies but every
single person with half a brain knows
that's absolute nonsense the central
bank is worried because if all of a
sudden there's 50 high inflation and
there's a alternative solution in
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies citizens
are going to eventually figure it out
and they're going to start dropping the
native currency and buying the currency
in the digital world that protects their
purchasing power and so what the central
bank is in effect doing is they're just
putting a capital control on these
citizens the currency's failing it's
being debased at a historic pace and now
the central bank quite literally wants
to trap their citizens in that currency
this is a nasty nasty game that gets
played and every single bank of
financial institutions gonna have to
decide will they comply or will they not
i don't have the answers there but what
i do know is that the argentinians that
are living through 50 inflation they
need solutions because literally they're
seeing their financial wealth evaporate
before their eyes
bitcoin provides that solution and
whether it's through the legacy banks
and financial institutions or it's
through some sort of crypto exchange or
even decentralized exchanges my guess is
that the pain and the problem is big
enough
that the argentinians are gonna figure
out how to get bitcoin this is just
another step along a very long journey
where people who have a native currency
that's failing start to realize that a
currency that's decentralized that's
digital and that isn't controlled by any
one person or group and can't be debased
unilaterally
probably is going to end up being
something they want to hold in the
future hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time